en tunisie le gel du parlement est la
levée de l'immunité des parlementaires
se prolongera ehsayer de le chef de
l'état est déterminé à poursuivre son
opération
anticorruption débuté le 25 juillet
dernier alors que la population et
l'opposition attend toujours la
formation d'un gouvernement et les
précisions de notre correspondant bassam
chez à tunis
une annonce publiée tard dans la nuit
une fois n'est pas coutume le président
de la république annoncé via les réseaux
sociaux la prolongation des mesures
d'exception en vigueur depuis le 25
juillet dernier alors que le gel des
travaux parlementaires et la levée de
l'immunité parlementaire des députés
devaient durer trente jours et se
terminer ce mercredi cahill sayyed a
annoncé la prolongation de ces mesures
d'exception et ce jusqu'à nouvel ordre
un scénario attendu pour de nombreux
tunisiens comme pour certains
spécialistes le président bien déterminé
à aller jusqu'au bout de son projet ne
semble pas être inquiet des retards
causés par l'absence de gouvernement et
la suspension des activités de
l'assemblée des représentants du peuple
depuis le 25 juillet dernier aucune
feuille de route n'a été annoncée par le
chef de l'état qui semble vouloir
prendre son temps pour opérer les
changements nécessaires selon lui dans
le pays alors que l'opposition elle
parle d'un coup d'état constitutionnel
le président continue de jouir du
soutien d'une large partie de la
population tunisienne même si cette
dernière reste suspendu à ces décisions
à commencer par la nomination d'un chef
du gouvernement le président ans sayyed
a répété agir strictement dans le cadre
de la loi et de la constitution adoptée
en 2014 le contexte de post révolution
face à l'inquiétude et tunisiens le
palais de carthage a indiqué que son
locataire allait prochainement
s'adresser à la nation sans pour autant
donner de date exacte